thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another amazingly happy
episode of careful Boaz I've never been
happier
we got Geo with us today yay
so since taika is so good at talking now
what are some of his best quotes that he
said lately we know about 45 books-old
my favorite which is what the clean
version of saying butthole yeah how did
he come up with that because it Rhymes
well he knows that like he can't say
butthole so he would say it everywhere
he would stayed in school
and can be evaluated
um just to see what was going on because
he was like on seizure medication and
then he was acting out at school like
not being able to sit still and he was
super irritable and we're like okay it
could be medication side effects or it
could be some like
um social skills psychological thing
that's going on with him so we were
getting both things evaluated and even
then when he was getting evaluated with
the psychologist
um she came out of the room that I was
waiting in while he was testing and she
goes
um so I think we're gonna have to stop
the testing early today because when I
was asking taika some specific questions
he just kept saying butthole and I was
like [__] so like he just
couldn't stop saying butthole such a bad
thing to do
such a thing
worse well it's because of Art
uh well he like thinks it's funny
but we need to keep a straight face cute
test stuff you know like stuff that's
like okay you got 30 seconds
um you see this now recreate this and
then I just patient word butthole
butthole butthole
our review is like those are my jeans
probably 100
your jeans are strong
it's yours that's GEOS yeah
um so that so then yeah so I was
threatening his little five-year-old
life I'm like bro I'm gonna [__] end
you right now
and then he was like all right [__] 25
bucks souls and I'm like oh it's 25
bucks 45 45 whatever 45 bucks so to get
around it like before it'd be like like
he knows that's the punch line so even
if it's like in real life oh my butt
itches my what it is and goes my
butthole but now he'll be like what it's
just my 45 bucks off
why 45. because I guess 45 bucks and
then so that you could 45 bucks isn't
anything wrong I like how you're
breaking down the five-year-old logic
I'm pretty sure it's just probably funny
yeah yeah because I get it yeah because
I because I get it because it's 45 cases
but box hole sounds like butthole and
it's also close enough where he if he
says it everyone else knows what he's
talking about so it's like that I think
you remember most of his little things
okay yeah 45 bucks you know all of his
things what else does he say
like what you know like he's he's in
that no filter he's in that no filter
stage right where he's just observing
[__] and just saying exactly for sure
remember when he told someone uh I
forgot what he would where we were he
was like man why is that person look so
old
was it an actual person yeah but I can't
remember it was just medium dude
I don't remember what else he says he
has so much today I like I like the
videos like Papa you have a Chinese face
yeah that's another top quotable right
again and he's not wrong
what did you say in response to that
I so yeah I do because it's never like
you're not ready to receive anything
like that you know you're like prepared
for it
so dramatic yes I guess I do and even
and even if you are like let's say you
like you put on your [__] baseball
outfit he's in his baseball outfit if it
catches me you're ready okay throw me
your best [__] baseball throw you
close your eyes when you open it it's
like a [__] water balloon or like
like just everything is curveballs all
the time with them yeah you just can't
even like yeah you cannot predict what
you can't prep for it
yeah that's so interesting he's
sharpening your skills as a comedian
yeah for sure do your kids do that
uh one of them [__] on my shoe the other
day oh yeah yeah that is a curveball
it's a water balloon they normally don't
[__] on your shoes right your shoe right
on the top oh right on the top right on
the top of the shoe and then throw my
shoes away creative did you look at it
and go kids will be kids I started
crying I was like I was like babe come
in here look what Leon did and then we
started crying together a little Scamp
oh my God he's grown up he's learning so
it's so cool Leon yeah
what's your what's the girl's name
Winnie
Winnie Winnie that's a nice name yeah
like Winnie Cooper yeah why is it lyanna
winning she wanted to name him uh she
wanted to name her Winnie and I want us
to name him Leon I thought it was a good
man so now you don't have names for your
real kids when they come along
you just used it up on these [__]
pugs real kids
are you
do you think I'm a fool
take me
do I look like the dumbest guy in the
world
look like the dumbest guy in the world
okay so it's some crazy things your kids
have said yeah yeah what's what's the
funniest one
you can't contain himself yeah I just
there's so many
because they just say so many
intelligent stuff throughout the day my
kids are non-verbal oh [__] yeah dude
they don't really talk that much
yeah dude there's still four months okay
there's still four months they actually
identify as pugs yeah so please just
watch your mouth it sure is scary when
you when you can't trace where this kid
is getting these
moments of dialogue from yeah or even
moments of anything yeah like when we're
uh at his basketball practice like
everyone's like dribbling around okay
beep my class about to start right so
the coach said all right everyone put
their balls to the side everyone goes
like this it puts it off to the side
because they're gonna go do some
Japanese taika grabs the ball and just
[__] launches it
as far back as he can like he's [__]
in a strong man complex literally like
whoosh like that and then I I look at
them and I'm like why why'd you do that
you know why you did
you never know why he does it why didn't
he do it if I had to guess if I put
myself in this [__] little like
[__] five-year-old pants it's
probably like magic
it's kind of cute very cute he probably
has always wanted to know what it feels
like to launch a basketball in a gym but
he can't because he'll get in trouble
because there's other games going around
so if the coach is like oh let's put her
stuff away him launching it is
technically not in trouble
and so he gets to do it's a technicality
he didn't specify how to put it away oh
that he finds Tom yes he's good at
loopholes huh so he's [__] he's your
accountant basically
exactly when he does [__] I don't even
ask Taiko why he did it I'm like why did
he do it why did he do it yeah
oh God this guy's a menace there was
this kid um he's like this nine-year-old
kid that used to hang out at the studio
in quest Learning Center back in the day
he's like the son of one of the owners
and he he came up to us one day and he
he just went you guys want to see me
pants myself
[Laughter]
and then he pulls it back up and goes
you thought
you thought yeah he goes yeah you
thought like like we basically like
psych yeah he's like saying psych we're
like no we didn't think that you were
gonna really show us are you weirdo yeah
get out of here man
like that's a dangerous thing to play
around with but yeah that's what that's
something that tiger likes to do where
uh we'll tell him to go take a shower
and then he goes into the bathroom to go
take a shower but then he's butt naked
now so he runs back outside he always
has to do every single day he runs back
outside and he goes here comes the naked
boy here comes
he does he does it every time so we went
let's go Airbnb we're like uh went to a
handle like Dave and our friends Anna
Jeremy yeah yeah yeah last weekend we're
like when you go shower you cannot sing
that song and you cannot come downstairs
that's why but it's so funny we're like
no one wants to see your pee pee dude
that's nasty like it kills
every time you got a better closer
and then uh well what were we doing
we're getting ready to swim and then why
did he pull his pants down to show his
people in front of all the adults what I
don't know
or he said something happened and he's
like Oh you mean like this and he pulls
down his peepee and all the dogs like
what the heck is going on and then we're
like hey put your PP put your PP away
and then he puts it away we go swim
whatever uh the next day there's a
trampoline in the back so he's bouncing
up and down oh no it was me and Jeremy
uh we're watching our kids play Oh No
and then taika looks like he's sweating
up a storm and on The Hitchhiker you
want to take your shirt off and he goes
I'm not gonna let anybody see my belly
and then Jeremy's like but his beep he's
okay I don't know dude
I don't know so it seems like a lot of
the things that Micah does you could
identify as like that's Bart's kid 100
what are some things where you go that's
Geo's kid when he blows his eyes
and he talks with his [__] hands like
this to be like Mom but you said and I'm
like stop doing that
don't talk to me like that like that his
attitude problem told you I wasn't lying
oh wow attitude
like his response to being told like
something like it's an attitude yeah
like he's clearly irritated and he's
just like
like this like this you had you have
that same thing now or as a kid
it's how he was amazing yeah like I'll
be like what are you doing and he's like
what are you doing
yeah yeah you better watch the [__] out
why you sound like your mom
draws all over his hands
oh my God
holy [__] you forgot
I was like why is he drawing on his head
and I'm like oh
does he ever just do flat out
impersonations of you guys
if he's so he hasn't been around Chinese
that much but like when my mom calls him
[__] oh that's good this is good you
have like three times
and I'm like that's you fool do you know
that oh he doesn't do that on the
Mexican Mexico
man so is he is he currently still
identifying as Chinese yeah or he don't
identify as Mexican at all not really
yet don't know why that's so funny yeah
maybe later for the second time it's fun
of the Chinese side it's funny
and is that something like when he makes
fun of like Chinese sounding stuff are
you trying not to laugh
or do you just he's laughing oh okay I
can't help it you trapped it I don't
know he's the worst I have to like me is
funny I have to clean it all up all the
time
my kid's good man I'm laughing but I
have to I have to I have to stay firm
like there's got to be someone I can't
and then there's times where I have to
like like I just have to like yell to
like get him intimidated a little bit so
I can just kind of laugh but yeah I have
to stand firm because this [__] won't
do it you know what game they play right
now what uh he goes Papa do you want to
play a game and then Bart's like yeah it
was okay let's play a game different
ways people die oh yeah so he's like
okay so he goes I'll go first
um I jump out of an airplane without a
parachute and then he goes okay you get
struck by lightning and then like they
keep going back and forth on how people
will that's creative games
what the [__] we can play anything else
hey he's a writer
he's very creative but I'm like bro and
then I'll be like okay now there's an
eagle that comes from the sky and he
goes and his Talon's pull your eyeballs
on your bleed everybody goes oh touche
game recognized game
they're going [__] dude like please
don't play this at school so I actually
want to bring it back for like an off
the Record and we play that game with
him dude I'll beat him bro
yeah I did and they'll just be quiet
because they're like good they're good
boys and girls and they'll just sit in
my lap okay but we have to eat feed them
[__] in your lap
or on Daddy's new pair of shoes
I bet Titans never [__] on your shoes
before no I think he has isn't he
because don't you guys share on the side
of the road all the time
all the time
I feel okay that's a reason only once oh
really for me and him to get
to get together I thought it was a
couple of times no I thought that was
because you said the trailer had like a
you couldn't get in so you had to pee on
the road yeah yeah that was the only I
don't know he likes there's multiple
situations of this he made [__] up a
couple times no no he was I was the only
one
dude what's some stuff that he was like
uh having a hard time learning not to do
and now he doesn't do it anymore peeing
in public oh yeah yeah yeah how public
like okay so uh this is before we moved
to Vegas we were still looking at
different properties and stuff and one
of them
um we went inside I think it was with
Grandma outside so we went inside to
kind of scope up the space we turn
around and all we see is five-year-old
[__] or [__] maybe four years
three or four year old yeah ass cheeks
just [__] pissing on the property the
lawn that we're looking at our Realtors
like
she's like oh my God
oh my God so yeah
that's what your kids do all the time no
that's just the funniest situation ever
too yeah you know like guess we're not
getting this house original open house
behavior is like so this is the bathroom
and this is the kitchen everyone's like
even like me and Geo we don't act like
this but when we're in there we're like
this
ones like this and they're pleasantries
and then you just turn around and you
know like those kids are t-shirts like
up here and the pants are all the way to
the floor yeah that's awesome in the
Korean market he did it too where I was
like oh my God no
potty training him and the way we did it
was dude just be butt naked and just
wear because we were always home he was
a coveted kid you know yeah so I'm like
wherever you got to be just pee it's
fine we'll work it out later but we just
didn't know that it was gonna happen in
public that would carry over I gotta pee
and he would just pull it down we're
like no dude not here yeah that's pretty
tough huh because there's a lot of stuff
that he does where it's like wrong in
public so how when it happens like how
do you guys he's confused yeah like how
do you guys teach him because he doesn't
know any better but he gets it 100 now
but we tell them yeah we tell them like
you're not in trouble but you're just
this is inappropriate you're not
supposed to do anything
and then he goes okay and then it
doesn't do it again he'll try to
remember it yeah okay that's good it's
not like night or night and day it
slowly gets there yeah do you guys like
yell at him first like as a response or
is it like try to calm him that or
because you know you might not be angry
that he's doing it or like how do you
guys dead not angry we're almost never
angry yeah that's good that's good yeah
we're almost there because we know he
doesn't know yeah we just like try to
make you like hey like one of Tyga's
favorite things especially when I'm
around he goes like this and then he's
just like
[__] yelling at him he just liked it
I'm like we're at a restaurant you can't
do that you know but if that's a guy
home I don't care if we're watching TV
and he just goes
I'm like that's fine I'll play with them
but I'm like hey like I think it was
about to do that a couple times today at
the funeral yeah and I was like you can
feel it coming off I feel like I'm
feeling like
I can't do that no not right now are you
talking about the ledge though because
once he gets close to that break before
yeah you can't do the beat that's the
first thing yeah this morning this I
didn't because this is the today was the
first time he ever did it in the morning
I barely woke up did you see what he did
no he socked me in the back
when you were asleep no I woke up I woke
up and I was just walking around the
kitchen and then he's in his pajamas
still he's never done it like Spider-Man
in the morning but I just hear him go he
socks me in the back
do you know what's hard too is like if
he's at home and he's taught to be
comfortable in himself at home but then
guests come over like how do you guys
like oh because it's like he's still
yeah yeah
[Music]
like like your kids
um no stop saying like that no I'm just
I'm just drawing the [__] uh what is
it the parallels here dude I thought
you're talking down to me
um no it's just the repetition part you
know because we know he's not doing it
out of like ill intent or like yeah you
know like there's nothing behind it like
it's just so innocent like dude not
right now like we don't do it here
what's the rule for like can he just
sock you anytime supposed to if we're at
home well so the rule is because we
don't want it to go to school just start
socking people up and so we have it
where you have to ask someone or you
have to ask Dad like are you can I play
oh yes then it's like you could do
whatever yeah
okay so play the circle of play yeah we
don't want like he just has a ball and
just throws it it's always like do you
want to play basketball okay then you
can play so this morning would have been
considered flagrant foul yeah that's a
two you didn't say nothing you just
oh man imagine he goes to school hey you
want to play they say yes
[Laughter]
we need another step yeah
yeah what about in Jiu Jitsu like how is
he acting like he [__] he's not
interested in it right now oh not right
now yeah I know he just [__] around so
he'll like let kids Mount him and then
he'll start tickling them
he just lays limp and he like lets them
just kind of like practice his defense
that's just a pacifist approach he'll be
like what's over there
[Music]
wait kind of smart a little bit but yeah
he doesn't care about it I don't think
he I don't think he uh likes yeah he's
bored he loves basketball that's where
his thing is yeah but Jiu Jitsu is just
something you want him to just have the
self-defense knowledge yeah so like be
comfortable with that yeah then you know
like it's one of those like wax on wax
off things where like I know he doesn't
like it but if we just do it even at the
bare minimum one day when he's like 10
and he runs into a bully he's gonna oh
[__] I know what to do right
tickle and lay there hey look over there
or he'll just charge up randomly like
[Laughter]
even when we go swimming like his Jiu
Jitsu kicks in like yeah you get on my
back and I'll feel him get his hooks in
yeah he gets his Hudson and then he does
his seatbelt which is like one arm is
under one is over and then he has Gable
so like regular people might grip like
this or whatever but this is specific
boobs dude yeah but there's a specific
like it's called Gable grip in like
grappling and he I see his little Gable
grip really tight so it's just like
those little things oh [__] it's
clicking named after Dan Gable a very
famous American wow
even when he falls he he's
just something that he rolls his eyes at
he doesn't really roll his eyes I think
he was just doing it no I know he does
yeah I'm rolling my eyes too and I miss
it yeah yeah at the same time so now it
will be it'll be like not as clever dab
jokes
he'll roll his eyes at me
it's a crowd yeah
what is it called
uh in front of my uncle's funeral they
dig like a big hole out of the ground
yeah and there's a piloter and then now
the bulldozers come in to put the dirt
back over the casket so he's like Papa
look what are they gonna do with the
dirt and I'm like oh let me make
pancakes out of it and then he goes
[Laughter]
just to cover up the the casket dude get
duh pancakes is fun man I don't only
[__] with them what I feel like the
answer is so obvious because I'm
actually telling him like you're
[__]
they're gonna do with the dirt yeah he's
five you son of a [__]
you're [__] my girl
what are you an idiot what are you
[__] five losers
go back to school at that field I went
to my uncle's funeral and they're making
pancakes
not even looking in the same direction
bro they're like this
and then
um also last thing I wanted to know
besides squats what's the other do you
have any other immediate like punishment
type for sure like what besides because
it's like the reference of like oh Duke
squats now because you did something
he's done push-ups uh we've had him do
burpees before
um
well he's really good wow it's starting
to backfire it is he likes it he's
getting too [__] well I'll be like
okay that's I was like I'll let you know
what that means that's 30 squats but
like I'll do a hundred he'll start doing
like like he's doing them in the first
time he's looking ten he goes you know
what I like doing these this is good for
my muscles and I'm like okay
you're not enjoying them right now yeah
he's like I had some weight yeah I had
some weight yeah it's a little too easy
burpees push-ups lunges you're at a wall
because you know how he's like he can't
like stop fidgeting like do you think oh
that's bad
for someone like him add that age would
just be it yeah no punishment where he
would she would just hate it I would
never do that it's just failure for sure
they wouldn't do it hey dude they could
if they did you make your son do after
he's shat in your shoe yeah you gotta
lick your mouth
[Music]
um
foreign